this video was made possible by audible
do your first audiobook for free at the
link in the description embassies are
the vessels through which diplomacy is
conducted
they are the physical manifestations of
countries abroad and they are crucial
tools in the field of international
relations these can range in size from
tiny like the UK Embassy in Mongolia
which only has a handful of staff to
enormous like the US Embassy in Baghdad
a complex physically as large as the
Vatican City which reached a peak of
sixteen thousand staff during the Iraq
war
big influential countries will have
embassies to almost every other country
the US for example has diplomatic
missions to every UN recognized country
in the world except st. Kitts and Nevis
Antigua and Barbuda
Dominica Saint Lucia Saint Vincent and
the Grenadines Grenada Guinea Bissau
Iran Bhutan and North Korea smaller less
influential countries on the other hand
might only have a few embassies to
follow for example only has diplomatic
missions to New Zealand Fiji Taiwan
European Union and Belgium and the
United Nations in New York you see there
are embassies to non-state organisations
namely the UN and EU you can even have
embassies to agencies of the UN there's
one US diplomat in Rome with a lengthy
title of United States ambassador to the
United Nations agencies for food and
agriculture even traditionally in closed
off countries like North Korea have
representation abroad the DPRK has
embassies in some quite Western
countries like Germany Sweden and the UK
and these three countries also each of
embassies in North Korea now part of the
way these embassies can exist in even
the most different and opposing of
countries is because of how they are
codified in international law every UN
member state except for South Sudan
Palau and the Solomon Islands has signed
the Vienna Convention on diplomatic
relations this sets out a number of laws
on how embassies work perhaps the most
significant and well-known is article 22
the premises of the mission shall be
inviolable unless invited by the
Ambassador or their government any
representative of the host country's
government be a police officer
government official member of the
military or even firefighter cannot
enter the embassy this of course is how
Julian Assange stayed in the Ecuadorian
Embassy in
London for seven years he entered in
2012 when he was wanted in the UK for
extradition to and subsequent arrests in
Sweden
Assange stayed in the embassy while his
request for Ecuadorian political asylum
was reviewed and once it was granted
normally the next step would be to go to
Ecuador outside the embassy though
waited British police and so he would
therefore have been arrested if he ever
left in the end though
after seven years inside it was the
British police that arrested Assange as
the Ecuadorians decided Assange had
overstayed his welcome and invited the
police inside the Vienna Convention also
lays out a few other important rules for
embassies the diplomats and the embassy
are exempt from all taxes in the host
country the diplomats are allowed free
movement around the host country an
embassy can have diplomatic couriers
carrying diplomatic bags which cannot be
seized or searched diplomats are granted
diplomatic immunity the residences of
diplomats are also treated as an
extension of the embassy and cannot be
entered without permission
diplomats cannot work or earn profit
when in their host country except for
with the embassy and then there are
plenty of other even more minor rules
now one big misconception about
embassies is that this is an embassy
it's not this is a Chancery the building
in which an embassy is located the
embassy is not the building it's the
group of people that work inside the
building it is the group of workers that
represent the country abroad another big
misconception about embassy buildings is
that they are the sovereign territory of
the country they represent this is not
the case it is also not the case that
embassy buildings are in a state of
extraterritoriality that local laws
don't apply there as would be the case
in the United Nations headquarters or in
many foreign military bases in the case
of embassy buildings it's not that the
laws of the host country don't apply
there it's just that many of the people
that make up the embassy the diplomats
can be prosecuted for violating those
laws and those that enforce the law the
police can't enter now diplomats almost
always follow the rules other host
country as failing to do so would be
unproductive for the very nature of
their job but when they don't this can
have serious implications as an example
in April 1984 to students in Tripoli
Libya were hung for publicly opposing
Gaddafi in response a protest was formed
by a major political opposition group
outside the Libyan embassy
London on order from Gaddafi an
individual inside the embassy building
fired into the crowd with a machine gun
wounding 11 one of those wounded was
Yvonne Fletcher a young police woman who
later died in the hospital from her
injuries within ten minutes of the shots
going off the embassy building was
surrounded by British police blocking
anyone from going in or out once he had
been confirmed through friends at
autopsy that the shots did indeed come
from the embassy negotiations began the
British tried to get permission to enter
the embassy building you see only some
but not all of the 30 people in the
building were diplomats meaning that
some if they were found to have
committed the crime could be arrested
for it the Libyans however would not
grant access therefore after five days
of surrounding the embassy the British
severed diplomatic relations with Libya
giving them another week to leave the
embassy and country this you see is what
countries can do when diplomats
misbehave they can't go into the embassy
building they can't arrest diplomats but
they can kick them out of their country
after this incident diplomatic relations
between the two countries didn't
normalize for decades and even today in
2019 the case is still actively under
investigation and is quite possible an
arrest could happen in the future
normally though embassies are more
concerned with building diplomacy
typically but not always embassies are
headed up by an ambassador sometimes
though there are lapses where one goes
without an ambassador for a period of
time and other times a country might
choose to recall their ambassador as a
sign of displeasure now the job of
ambassador is tough to define in
simplest sense an ambassador is there to
represent their country but what that
entails varies widely from person to
person and post post there's often a
perception that all their ambassadors to
is schmooze and booze but to be honest
that's part of the job
they're there to build and maintain
relationships with those that can help
their country politically economically
or otherwise that's just part of
diplomacy which is what the Embassy's
job as a whole is this can be direct
diplomacy where the Ambassador might
meet directly with a head of state or
soft diplomacy soft diplomacy can be
things like China sending pandas to
foreign zoos the u.s. funding
scholarships for foreign students or
France signing up a branch of the Louvre
Madhavi they are more subtle ways that a
nation can curry public favor with
another on a smaller scale embassies
will often have a portion of staff
dedicated to promoting and exhibiting
the art and culture of their country in
the region you'll often see embassies
financially supporting and sponsoring
concerts of their countries music for
example now in addition to these ways of
representing one's country the embassy
also represents is homeland through its
actual building as the public face of
one country in another it's got to look
the part for example some of the world's
most impressive and important embassies
are in Washington DC given that nearly
every nation has a diplomatic mission
there the Chinese embassy building was
designed by the children of I M Pei a
chinese-american regarded as one of the
world's greatest architects and evokes
the same sense of clean contemporary
grandeur and opulence common with the
greatest buildings back in the People's
Republic itself while still adhering to
Fung Shui principles just down the
street there is the embassy building of
the United Arab Emirates perhaps even
more opulent structure clearly
incorporating aspects of Islamic
architecture this building seems to
purposely command a presence with its
open sight line from the street allowing
one to look in and up then there's this
section of the British Embassy complex
nearby a structure resembling an old
English country manor while countries
like China and the UAE might be more
focused on pushing their modern image as
newly wealthy nations countries like the
UK might draw more attention to their
long and storied past then there's the
whole realm of the architecture of
American embassy complexes themselves
with necessity after countless attacks
on its embassies through history the
architecture and design of American
embassy buildings evokes security
whether it's the one in Berlin Beijing
Berner Bangkok they all have the look of
a compound they're mostly modern
innovative designs a conscious choice to
associate these values to the nation's
image but they're still mostly hidden
behind tall walls and fences there are
still some though mostly in places where
security is less of a concern reflecting
the earlier architectural style of the
u.s. such as the Georgian house of the
US Embassy in Canberra Australia a
building that would look right at place
in the American South but when embassies
are in certain places their buildings
can't just be compound style the
to be compounds as the physical
representations of countries embassies
are the clearest targets for those
wishing to send a message to a country
during Wars though there is often more
work than ever for embassies to do in a
country this is why as mentioned earlier
the u.s. embassy in baghdad iraq
balloons over 16,000 staff during the
iraq war the embassy building was built
in the Green Zone a highly fortified
area along the Tigris River in Baghdad
this area guarded by soldiers and malls
more than nine feet or three meters tall
was in still is home to much of the
international presence in Baghdad that
included embassies of countries like the
US UK and Australia but also some
companies war is big business and the
Green Zone was home to small field
headquarters for many large
international engineering construction
and private military firms contracted to
help in the war that is to say the Green
Zone was primarily home to a large group
of civilians working in Iraq which is
why was so heavily guarded given the
security threat the US Embassy there was
built to be entirely self-sufficient it
has its own generators its own wells its
own water filtration plant its own
sewage plant its own fire station it
even has its own internet uplink to
circumvent the Iraqi Network it has its
own phone network both wired and
wireless which both operate pretty much
as if they were in the u.s. they used
the area codes of New York and Virginia
unlike in most cities where embassy
staff just live in normal housing in the
city this embassy has its own block of
fortified apartments even during the
thick of war the embassy compound had
its own swimming pool tennis courts
fitness center department store nail
salon and movie theater topping it off
is a helicopter pad used to get the
Ambassador and other top diplomats
around the country when they don't want
to confront the dangers of below the
diplomats serving as part of the US
Embassy in Baghdad do get another perk
in addition to the pool and tennis
courts and movie theater and everything
else they get more money
you see when working in the u.s. Foreign
Service and it's often similar when
working for other countries is foreign
service you essentially get more money
to more foreign a place you go if you're
serving pretty much anywhere in North
America Western Europe Australasia and a
few other assorted countries you get no
bonus if you serve in a place that has a
Next
climate poor quality of healthcare high
crime high pollution or has any other
factor that makes it more difficult to
live there as a foreigner you get
hardship pay which is a bonus that
ranges anywhere from five to thirty five
percent that five percent rate includes
places like Costa Rica the Bahamas Malta
and Bulgaria
well the thirty five percent rate is
reserved for places like the Central
African Republic Somalia Libya Syria
Iraq Afghanistan and Pakistan that rate
of hardship pay can also vary within a
country for example if you served at the
US consulate in Dubai you'd only get a
five percent bonus while serving at the
US Embassy in Abu Dhabi would get you
ten percent
there are also some places that well
just don't seem all that hard to live in
but do earn you hardship pay such as
punta delgada portugal a well known
vacation destination this is likely only
included because of its isolation on top
of hardship pay you can also get an
additional bonus if you serve in a place
that is deemed dangerous for example
port-au-prince Haiti gets you 15% more
places like Tripoli Damascus Kabul
Baghdad and Juba will get you a 35
percent bonus so any place like Baghdad
you get a 70 percent bonus just for the
hardship and danger you put yourself
through this is how they get people to
work at even the harshest of postings
without forcing them on top of these two
they're also some other bonuses based
off things like high cost of living
difficulty in staffing the post and more
now in the modern age some have
questioned whether embassies still have
a purpose 100 years ago they very much
had a purpose as communication was
difficult travel was slow and countries
therefore needed someone on the ground
who could speak on their behalf to
others at a moment's notice
nowadays though messages can be related
instantaneously through a whole host of
means so what's the point
well ambassadors are not messengers
ambassadors are representatives they are
there not only to work for their country
within political systems but also to
promote it to the public as to increase
travel and trade with their country many
argue in fact that these small personal
relationships of our world's diplomats
tying together countries of hundreds of
millions or billions are more important
now
than ever if you want to work in the
foreign service the US State Department
has an extensive reading list of books
that will help you get the knowledge you
need no matter which country you're from
one book on there that I found quite
interesting was blink the power of
thinking without thinking by Malcolm
Gladwell the book is all about how the
unconscious brain works in making
decisions with very limited info blink
like so many other books is available as
an audiobook on audible
so you can listen to it wherever and
whenever I find that listening to books
helps me fit a lot more in and it helps
make things like cleaning or commuting a
lot more fun best of all you can sign up
for free at audible.com slash Wendover
or text Wendover to 500 500 and download
blink or any other audio book for free
in addition to to audible originals also
for free